so remember the fake outrage over the
Christmas song Baby It's Cold Outside
you're supposed to be very mad about
that song part of a broader effort to
destroy everything you grew up with that
was good your history your culture but
they told us the time was me too well
comedian Tom Cotter remembers that very
well and he noted that that song
generated a lot more outrage among
lifestyle liberals than a pop song about
women's genitals so Tom cotter's bit on
this is all over the Internet you may
have seen it if you haven't here's part
of it and the one that really killed me
was last Christmas we canceled a song
that was written in the 1940s called
Baby It's Cold Outside which is fine if
you feel that way but at the exact same
time the number one song in this nation
for over two months was yeah I'm not
begging that up you can look it up
Google it so I want to wrap up My Show
by comparing and contrasting the lyrics
of these two songs
[Applause]
[Laughter]
if indeed this country has lost its mind
shall it let's start with the hardly
offensive Christmas song written just
after World War II
I really can't stay Baby it's cold
outside I gotta go away Baby It's Cold
Outside this evening has been so very
nice
yeah you with some wet
putting a bucket and a mop for this
wedding
beat it up and we're an extra large
extra hard put this right in your face
swipe your nose like a credit card
so when you destroy people's culture
you replace it with something new a new
culture and he pointed out what the new
culture is and it's not just Baby it's
cold outside because it's not just one
song it's everything you grew up with
everything that you thought made this
country decent all the happy memories
from your child that are now banned so
that would include Christmas carols like
God Rest Ye Merry Gentlemen
we found this video from 2020 of people
singing the new woke version of God Rest
You Weary gentlemen here it is
[Music]
so again the point is not to make it any
more inclusive it's to destroy the
things that you love Tom Cotter of
course knows that comedians are really
insightful that's why they're comedians
Tom cutter who just saw joins us now Tom
thanks so much for coming on so what
inspired you to compare yesterday's
deeply offensive song with today's
totally okay song
yeah I'm not trying to bash anyone over
the head with my politics but I just
think you got to draw a line in the sand
somewhere like uh I consider Christmas a
birthday party it's a birthday party for
the baby Jesus and these people want to
destroy a kid's birthday party which I
think is outrageous they wake up in the
morning waiting to be outraged what can
I be triggered by today so I can become
a Christmas Karen and ruin it for
everybody else and how long before white
Christmas is deemed racist or uh ho ho
ho is not you know offensive to people
in the entertainment industry or candy
canes or offensive to handicapped people
you got to draw a line somewhere or it's
just going to get further and further
out of control and I'm just done with
the woke people destroying it well I
completely agree and oh oh is offensive
to sex workers as you know but we say it
anyway
um so so what's the response when you
when you point this out in the hilarious
way you do
well I've been eviscerated by some uh
you know what kills me is it's it's
young Millennial men that are really
coming after me uh I thought it would be
maybe I'm I'm sexist but I thought it
would be Millennial women but it's
really the men that are coming after me
um and really taking shots at me on on
my posts and stuff but most people the
vast majority are are positive because I
think the vast majority believe as I do
that these are Traditions that we hold
dear that we we've hold on to for our
whole lives my kids have never asked
what Santa's pronouns are they don't
care you know what I mean and what about
the systematic oppression of the elves
when do we give them reparations and how
come the reindeer aren't more inclusive
they're all cisgender males aren't they
that little Prancer maybe but uh you
know we at some point you just have to
say no there shouldn't be an elk or a
caribou they're reindeer they went after
the Santa Claus the Movie by Tim Allen
they said it was fat shaming it's Santa
he's fat
can we get over it can we just move on
with our lives and not ruin it for kids
Tom Carter thank you
thank you so much
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight